wiese république ça peut pas être
racisme antisémitisme et révisionnisme
la devise de la république ces libertés
égalité fraternité zemmour portent des
pulls sur morges porte des pulsions de
vie zemmour au fond reprend
essaye de réconcilier une partie de la
france avec l'algérie française avec
pétain avec l'antisémitisme seymour et
juif mondial or c'est à dire qu'en fait
il fait le juif de service pour les
antisémites et ça c'est vrai que c'est
grave ce que vous dites là bien sûr mais
c'est extrêmement grave que porte eric
zemmour dans la société alors est-ce que
ce que c'est une faute politique pour
vous
bernard montiel oui oui c'est une faute
politique et je suis déçu parce que je
les aime bien ce monsieur est possible
et c'est son premier dérapage cela dit à
toulon dérape quand on est comme ça
interrogé tous les jours avec des
journalistes mais roman c'est
inadmissible la bonne solution c'est de
faire comme christiane taubira
premier set se taire quand on saute et
on gagne des bricks and viral faite
quant à ses pales fait le père fouras
les rivaux des jeux je comprends
exactement ce qu'il veut dire je vois ce
qu'il veut dire voilà je vois où il veut
en venir et évidemment yannick jadot
n'est absolument pas antisémite bien
évidemment mais mais mais c'est le terme
juif de service on peut pas accepter
arabes de service nombre de serveurs est
juif de service s'il avait dit zemmour
et la caution morale de l'extrême droite
voilà pourquoi pas c'est une idée on
peut la débattre on peut être d'accord
pas d'accord mais mais ça n'aurait shop
a pas choqué c'est je comprends son
raisonnement mais à signer quelqu'un à
sa religion ou son origine c'est pas
possible je devrais de des noms oui est
dit est dit est dit c'est bien vu
alors moi je trouve que yannick jadot
fait une entrée spectaculaire dans la
dans la campagne suite à cette
déclaration je trouve que c'est pas du
tout choquant et je pense que ceux qui
sont choqués n'ont pas compris ce qu'il
a voulu dire ce qu'il dit alors
expliquez nous et pour moi en tout cas
pour moi peut-être que je me trompe
peut-être que je suis voix mais moi j'ai
trouvé que c'était très clair et très
pertinents en gros il dit
quand zemmour dit qu'en gros pet a sauvé
les juifs ou quand il dit que l' affaire
dreyfus zemmour comptent zemmour dit l'
affaire dreyfus oui c'est pas vraiment
comme ça que ça s'est passé il dit
finalement que zemmour en fête permet
aux antisémites et aux racistes ceux de
la trétoire de caution à m c'est un
animé au fait on fait un paravent au
point je comprends ce que vous dites et
c'est je pense que ce qui sait ce qu'il
a voulu dire oui c'est une expression
quand l'extrême gauche mais indigéniste
disent que c'est l'arabe de service le
[ __ ] de salon
desserviront servi si ça vient votre
passion qui me disent les fondations
j'aime pas ça s'est passé comme la ces
comme je vous dis moi y'a un truc aussi
j'ai passé racaille mais rabat et c'est
que je déteste les gens qui n'y sera
pour moi c'est un côté c'est une
connotation raciste similaires voilà je
vous prie d complexe en fait le zemmour
d plex les antisémites à il aurait
d'après ma chambre mais oui mais sauf
qu'on est à la radio il à radio j donc
c'est pas moche et la radio j donc ils
veulent une sortie spectacle paradis les
ans quand balladur chirac radio génome à
d'autres communautés mais vous savez
c'est l'excès comme zemmour il est à bfm
avec zina edit ah mais moi aussi je suis
d'alger je suis d'algérie moi aussi
j'aime l'algérie moi aussi en gros je
mange du couscous et j'aime bien ça
c'est juste pour montrer pour
décomplexer pour dire vous pouvez voter
pour moi même et à ce que je suis parti
j'ai rallyes le rallye bilan n'aura pas
gilles verdez ne pas faire de moi je
suis pas du tout d'accord c'est
méprisant ça peut être qualifiée d'
injure publique dans nos ventes 2020 il
avait déjà dit ça laissait un petit cola
boats allons donc il récidive ils
l'attaquent sur sa personne et c'est
très mauvais pour moi c'est un dérapage
antisémite tout simplement
mais c'est le monde à l'envers depuis
hier on voit des hashtags jadot
antisémite c'est tout le contraire il
combat l'antisémitisme c'est en fait ce
qui est reproché à eric zemmour c'est
très clair c'est qu'il joue sur le fait
d'être de confession juive pour se
permettre de tenir des propos qui
peuvent être perçus comme antisémite
mais qui peut tenir parce qu'il est juif
donc sur le fond on est d'accord ou pas
avec lui mais sur la forme il ya aucun
dérapage ce moment idées complexes et il
y en a qui disent il y en a sur les
raisons qui dit ce qu'il a il était plus
maladroit
comme ça raymond mais alors moi je vais
dire un jour je vais dire avec taylor de
service et quand vous avez ma classe je
vais dire bassij étaient maladroits la
faute maladroit mais 21 juif de service
bah c'est maladroit si tu fais le gym de
services tous les soirs des pmp ses
droits c'est l'expression qui dira non
c'est maladroit et même là sur le
discours marché c'est d'accord avec cd
d'antisémite et si on veut que ça deale
ainsi on veut que ça c'est très
émotionnel veux que ça s'arrête toutes
ces mots là qu'il ces mots là si on veut
que la sar est l'arabe de service veut
dire un mec imbattable et l'arabe de
service à expocité l'arabe de service au
pardon c'était maladroit et la
conscience arabe de service pas pour
traiter non mais c'est pas possible des
trucs comme ça ouais pas de
10 ha non même si tu as carrément que ce
soit à des fins positives ou négatives
là pour lui ben c'était pour lui et pour
défendre ou je ne sais quoi moi je
trouve que l'expression elle se dit pas
parce qu'après on peut litige ils ont
des choses négatives donc que ce soit
pour des choses petit à petit on y dit
pas arabe de service aux dix pages il me
dit rien et quand même il dit lydie jus
de crs pour expliquer qu'en fait quand
on est jeune on peut se permettre de
remettre en cause des choses est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui sont
malheureusement pas suffisamment
intelligent et cultivé et je trouve ça
extrêmement dangereux de l'eau sur ce
drôle scola vous non mais ça carrément
ça peut carrément être a sanctionné par
la loi parce que journaliste qui a été
condamné à 1500 euros d'amendé 2000
euros de dommages intérêts pour injure
publique en traitant une syndicaliste
politique de la police deux arabes de
service alors il a dit que c'était pour
dénoncer justement à quelque chose de
politique
figure la même cas de figure et raymond
a raison si on peut faire des pas même
sa jambe ce genre d'excusés je ne vous
demande pas les stylisé parce qu'on a
des sondages ou pas les chéris bien ce
que c'est fini tout ça c'était l'ancien
temps oui 64% 67% n'ont atteint 20%